all right
francesca yes francesca where'd you grow
up where are you from originally
i'm from san francisco california north
beach
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents as a kid i had both of
my parents
but i've lived with my mother and my
father was around but my mom and father
weren't together
how would you describe your childhood i
had a good childhood i really did um
i had fun as a kid no no traumatic
events no abuse
no no nothing crazy went on no i know
my mother i know she used to do drugs
but um
she kind of hit it very well okay and
and what time do you wanna turn off your
phone maybe okay no
okay let's start it there we go so uh
what age were you when you left home so
what age yeah
what age did you leave home um like 16
17 going on yeah i mean i still lived
with my mother
but like i was out running the street
when i was like 16. you know and i
barely went home
i had a boyfriend and i started doing
bad things like i used to sell drugs
and a lot of things but yeah what age
did uh
drugs come in the picture for you um
like
like 16 years old 16. what drugs were
you using
i first started off smoking marijuana
wheat
and then drinking then ecstasy
and then coke coke led to crack cocaine
and that's what you use today yes
that's my drug of choice it's crack
cocaine i also use
black hair on there's different forms of
using it
i like to smoke it i've shot it before
but it's not my my thing i don't like
needles and i don't like to be
i don't like downers i like uppers where
do you where do you stay now you're
living in
i'm everywhere right now i'm practically
homeless um
i mean i've had it all um but i've lost
it in the blink of an eye
i have a son he's gonna be 12 years old
in a few days he actually lives with a
father he's been living with the father
for the past year
i've had three leases before
and my third lease
it was my dream my dream home you could
say
i had a boyfriend at the time and i went
to jail i haven't got in trouble in 13
years
somehow i got in trouble in the wrong
county at that and
um i didn't want to lose my place so i
took the offer
that they were given to me which led me
to get a strike
which i didn't know too much information
about but that was the worst thing i
could have ever done
um any trouble i get like any felonies
anything like that can get me to go to
prison for a long time
with having a strike and i took it
because they said to do nine months with
no strike in three years probation or
75 days with a strike in three years
probation i took the strike with the
three years probation only because i
wanted to save my housing
at that time my boyfriend had my my atm
card to pay my rent
but he didn't pay the cell phone bill
which had me curious of um
losing my place i didn't know whether
you know he does drugs too so
you know people that do drugs you know
they don't know how to like function and
keep things on task but i was a
functional
addict you know i've always paid my my
rent you know i had no problem with that
you know
i had side hustles that would get me
high and
so i had no problem with paying my rent
i didn't want to be homeless
so i went to jail i had a boyfriend that
didn't pay my rent
i eventually got evicted i couldn't take
care of my son
he had to go with the father i'm kind of
doing what i want right now
i've been wasting a lot of time to be
honest with you i'm not really
on my job my job right now is to
actually find housing again you know i
have an eviction
on my record now and it's going to be a
little difficulty but i don't want to
give up because i always tell everybody
never give up and i go by that you know
never give up keep on trying because you
will get it you know and so with that
being said yeah technically i'm homeless
right now and my son is living with a
father so
how do you support yourself today i um
receive social security
issi and i receive
food stamps and i
date i do
online dating i walk the streets
and i pretty much use my looks and
you know what i have yeah to get by that
could be a dangerous lifestyle right
it comes in hand in hand with the drugs
you know and
if i want to get high you know which my
drug is
never ending you know constantly chase
it you know i'm searching for that next
hit i'm searching
to get high i want to stay high you know
i do what i do honestly
to get high that's the honest truth i've
been there and done it i've
i've know what it is and i know what
guys do because the guys i've hung
around with we get guys you know
i'm gonna get girls i mean hi and they
know that they're gonna want another one
because that drug once you take one
you're gonna want another one and it's
never gonna stop after that it just
keeps going and going going and i'm the
type that i chase it
my mother used to smoke crack okay and i
knew she was doing something when i was
little she'll blow something in closet
but as i got older
i became to do drugs with her and we did
crack together and
you know she's a type that a smoke but
she'll put it out at the end of that day
and she won't chase it and the next few
days she'll do it again i'm the type
once i hit it i'm going on for the next
two three days until i fall out
and so um yeah my drug of choice is
crack cocaine
i also do black chiva i smoke it on a
foil i smoke cigarettes and i smoke weed
i know quite a lot of habits um
but my most number one drug of choice is
crack cocaine you've been arrested
before
yes i have been arrested before what
kind of stuff for
i got arrested for prostitution i've got
arrested
for um drugs
um pretty much yeah
drugs prostitution paraphernalia
uh really that's oh robbery
robbery what do you think most outsiders
don't understand about this lifestyle
they'll drive through this neighborhood
the tenderloin and see these drug
addicts a lot of people look down on us
you know what i'm saying because i mean
there was a time where i stopped drugs i
was clean for seven years and i
would look down on people like me and i
don't know why i did that
because you should never look down on
anybody especially when you've been
there and done it and you
were in those shoes before and i hated
that i done that you know i used to hate
when people smoke weed by my window
or any of that you know so we get looked
down a lot on down here in the streets a
lot of people do think that my lifestyle
is easy
and that my job that i do is easy it's
not i might make it look good but it's
not for everybody and
you know it's a it's it's really hectic
you know i'm saying it it's hard every
day and you know i get low balled every
day you know
it's the difference between working the
internet and then walking the streets
you know a lot of people
you know i'm saying it's like value went
down
on you know [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying like everybody thinks it's twenty
dollars ten dollars you know and i don't
believe on that especially me
being a caucasian female and i mean look
at me i
you know i really deserve all that and
more and i low ball myself just
so i can hurry for get the money to go
you know but
um other than that you know um
this lifestyle is not something you
would want to choose or
to be and you know it's it's not good
and i know it's not good and i look too
pretty and good to be out here on the
street they'd be like why are you out
here
but you know i don't really care what
people think you know because i gave up
on what people think about me
you know i used to care what people
think about me before i used to
hide that i smoked crack and i used to
wait and
so everybody was gone and smoke but now
i spark on the street anywhere on the
street you know right before you came
and got me i was sparking up and hit on
my pipe you know so
it was just like it's just like that you
know i don't care anymore and that's the
part i hate
i want to care but i don't and that
sucks
what do you think about your childhood
you know maybe it was the parents maybe
uh it has nothing to do with my parents
it just has a lot to do with the people
i hung around with
you know the crowd that i hung around
with it i don't i
a lot of people do have a reasons for
smoking you know and a lot of and the
reason why i smoke too is because
i'm hurting you know i was i mean i was
in a bad breakup
you know i'm still hurting from that you
know it hurts and so
um and my mother my mom passed away so
that's another reason and um i lost my
housing and everything
so you know it hurts um
but other than that a lot of times i
smoke because i like the feeling
and i like you know to cover my pain and
then
i feel a lot of pain you know and so i
just want to smoke and numb my pains i
don't want to feel anything
and um i got to the point where i got
used to getting high
like this to where i'm not happy without
it you know
i really ain't and i i'm bored with
myself like i don't know what to do with
myself you know like i have all the time
in the world to think about what i
should do but i honestly don't know what
to do
if i could keep myself busy and find a
job
or do something with myself but it's to
the point where i need to have a drug to
get up now
like if i don't have a drug i don't have
energy i don't i can't
fully get up i just want to lay in bed i
can't even care for myself i can't even
cook i can't
i can't do nothing you know it sucks to
be dependent on a drug you know
have you had bad experiences working the
streets and having guys
pick you up and stuff like that um yeah
like sometimes i might meet the wrong
guy
and like um he might not be happy with
my service or something and try to ask
for the money back or try to take it
from me it's dangerous
the lifestyle i live you know i can meet
the wrong person and my life can just
end you just never know
and there's a lot of crazy guys out
there you know and they're into tricking
women
and playing games with them and so you
know sometimes it's good to have
somebody
that's going to be there with you and um
guide you if you were in that game you
know i'm the type that i don't like to
pay
guys and pimps and stuff like that i've
never like
paid pimps and i had a boyfriend i mean
if you want to call it boyfriend pimping
you know but
other than that like i don't choose to
pay pimps you know i don't believe in
that you know so
um yeah this lifestyle is kind of hectic
you know you're
just stand back and look at where your
life is today and go man this is crazy
yeah it is crazy i wish i could go back
in time and change things and
i just wish i never would have went in
that car that day where
i got in trouble and i took the man's
phone and
he'd just be english um i was wow
the the the buses stopped running in
that area at seven
and i didn't have a car and i just
hopped in everybody's car
the first three cars didn't want to give
me a ride i asked politely i wasn't
intending
to rob them or any of that because then
that time being i was kind of walling
out robbing people for their phones and
stuff so i can
sell it and get money for crack or
whatever but at that time i just really
simply just wanted to write he didn't
say yes or no on the third card and opt
in and he's saying so i stayed in the
car he was on his phone
he picked up a client he's an uber
driver and then next you know we're
driving i'm thinking he's gonna give me
a ride
because he didn't say yes or no he
didn't respond but actually in reality
he didn't speak english and that's why
he didn't spoke
but i was led to believe that okay i'm
gonna get a ride but we're driving he
got his client in the back and we're
driving in the opposite direction so i'm
believing in my heart he's not taking me
where i
want to go so i requested for him to
stop
the car in the middle of the freeway you
know because he's not going in the
direction i want to go
and um i grabbed the wheel boom boom
i did a lot of bad things just put it
like that and it caused me to put my
hands on him i didn't
punch him or anything in his face i just
shook him up and you know doing things
like that
is it's dangerous it's violent and then
taking the phone that's
so it's robbery and fear and being in
san mateo county
you know they really don't play san
francisco you can get away with a lot of
things
so i that's i got in trouble and
um there you go so
in a way um getting in trouble kind of
got me to worry about a lot of things i
do now because i can't afford to get in
any trouble and a lot of things that i
do do nowadays
it's a lot of bad things you know i
shoplift you know what i'm saying i do
bad things and i'm scared that i don't
want to go to jail again
because any felony can if i get any
felony
i can go straight to prison for like 32
months i've never been in prison i've
been a county jail
the most i ever did was six months and
when i did the six months
i went to jail twice on my boyfriend the
second time he fell in love with a woman
and it broke my heart
and um it sucks because you know i'm
pretty girl people like why you don't
have a boyfriend a man and i just don't
you know
a lot of guys out here they don't take
relationships serious
you know it's all about what you could
do for them you know you would have to
go to another country and
people value things over there and you
know value family god
and you know just all of that you know
over here nobody values nothing
everybody takes everything for granted
you know i'm saying because every er we
get everything handed to us over here
you know it is true
you know like we get free phones we get
this you know it's just like
it's like that over here you know and it
sucks for the people that do work they
work hard for their money
and they don't get as much as we do it's
like you know a lot of people look down
on us and i don't blame them but
yeah so how do you feel like
this life living on the streets has
changed you have you become more
suspicious or
uh it made me lower myself a lot you
know like
i should believe i'm worth more but i've
like
i feel like wow what i've like done
things for certain money for the price
just dropped
tremendously and it's like sucks it's
like
wow you know what i'm saying like i
can't believe myself for that drugs
you know i dropped myself so low and so
and it's it's just not it's not good to
live like this not knowing where you're
going to sleep so every day like my
hustle
and my thing is make money get a hotel
i learned to not put the drugs first
anymore the drugs don't come first no
more my hotel room comes first because i
need a place to stay
you know to do the drugs you know so i
need a place so every day in the hotel
i'm at you know they work with me you
know like i can pay some later some now
and i like that you know they let me
bring a client or two up there
because i spoke with them you know in
order to pay that rent i need their help
so you know what i'm saying in order i
need to bring a person or two and you
know that let me so
my room is first and the drugs you know
so that's how it goes
all right francesco well thank you so
much for talking with me and good luck
getting
getting off the crack and getting home
our house
housing yes thank you and god bless
thank you
you